excuse me uh partner
um
yeah
um have you read the book The Evolution
of Desire
uh evolution of Desire no I haven't read
that yeah yeah well that phrase
literally is just distilling the whole
theory of that book into one little
phrase they hang out at the Finish Line
to pick the winner they're the sexual
selectors so it's not a it's not an
absolute you know one state and I can't
Define life but it's a rough guide and a
good guide okay and if you read that
book you'll it'll explain exactly what
that phrase means
so um question for a person so yeah you
said that you read my book and that you
agreed with someone with it I didn't
read the whole thing I listened to it
and I just couldn't keep going
um so yeah so what brought you to the
book first of all so why did you buy it
I had a friend on on stereo who was kind
of talking kind of red pill-ish and you
I wouldn't say he was like I was a coach
to him but I was kind of like just like
kind of watching him seeing where he's
going in his mindset who is it huh who
was it I might know him I think his name
was Junior
and I was like okay and I heard you talk
to some women and I was like oh man this
guy knows what he's talking about you
know but then I kind of heard like more
of the red pill stuff and then I was
like whoa wait a minute you know how
like you hear something and you're like
okay I kind of agree with that but
doesn't mean I have to agree with
everything and it's just like whoa whoa
and then some of the stuff you don't
agree with it's just like throws throws
you completely back you know kind of for
me it was just like whoa and then I
started getting into Rich Cooper and I
was like let me listen to this unplugged
Alpha book you know there's got to be
some sense in this someone this there's
got to make some some this comes from
somewhere and as I was listening it was
just like okay okay and then like I
think chapter two where it got to the
time the point where the I took some
notes but it got to the point where
um if a woman says no to you then you
know then you're not Alpha enough
basically I'm paraphrasing I know but
it's like
chapter two women's rules how they break
them and how they make them yeah right
and so and women break rules for alpha
males they make roles for beta males so
you have a good young man in my mindset
I'm thinking about the young men that I
would talk to any young man not even the
one on stereo but
and he is you know hearing this thing
and he's like well she says she doesn't
want to sleep with me or treat her like
a prison mate you know and because she
doesn't want me to do do that to her
that means she would allow some other
guy to do that to her instead of saying
maybe she values her body maybe she
values herself and she doesn't want to
do that but now he feels
um not Alpha enough maybe he has all the
high value stuff a man quote that that
has but she says no I'm not letting you
treat me like a cell mate and he's like
oh well then I'm not Alpha enough and so
he may feel like forget this she might
be going doing that with someone else so
she's thinking about Chad and she's like
oh well he's doing that with Chad but
she's not doing that with me and now his
mindset he's all jacked up in the head
because he thinks that because she won't
let him you know do whatever tell you
something dude guys that guys that get
mad when they don't get results haven't
learned how to deal with rejection yet
and unfortunately
yeah and unfortunately a lot of guys
haven't been taught how to deal with
deal with rejection and when they find
stuff
um like my book or other you know
creators out there in the man of swamp
who
um say similar things but slightly
differently
um you know the reality of it all is
that a lot of these guys aren't high
value
um I've had guys calling in my show many
times and they're like but I'm a high
value man it's like no you're not you
know you can't even wear the hat that
you want when you leave your house like
how are you a high value man like your
wife is [ __ ] on you for leaving a
toilet seat up and you're falling on my
shot yeah like that's not a high value
guy like that's a guy that's struggling
to maintain frame and the relationship
so a lot of the guys will just default
to like you know convenience and I never
tell guys to default to convenience My
slogan you know has been for years do
the damn work you know level yourself up
men must make something out of
themselves and when they come to a
nihilistic uh view of themselves lives
uh you know their lives a sexual
Marketplace that's when they start doing
dumb [ __ ] like oh I'm never gonna get a
girl because my jawline's not straight
enough and they go and pay some dip [ __ ]
on the internet money to like assess
their face and like give them a score
like there's a lot of people out there
that do stuff like that that aren't
being useful to guys in masculinity and
look dude I'm on your side like I want
guys to have a good experience it sounds
like you feel like you have a good
experience but the problem that I hear
with you as I'm talking to you is that
you're ignorant to a lot of facts that
could come back and bite you in the ass
later on down the road they may or may
not bite you in the ass but they could
come back and bite you very hard and at
some point maybe in five or ten years
you might come back I may be around
maybe I'm not be like yo Rich you were
right I should have paid a 10 attention
to these things so there there's a guy
out there I'm not going to mention any
names moths I'm not a big name mentioner
but um that would you know that would
disagree with moth on stereo like
hardcore and one thing he asked me he
was saying oh you know and he's like
liberal or whatever maybe he's like
person or how do you know your wife's
not cheating on you yeah like when you
leave the house or whatever and for me
I'm just like that's it's an
impossibility it's a zero no it's you
don't know with 100 certainty you're
right yeah you never know and that's why
I asked if you had the experience
because when you do have experience I
realize that Notch count is an end-all
be-all metric for all guys like my first
girlfriend I wanted to marry to but I
was blindsided by the fact that none of
them was she cheated him with one guy
but two guys because why I didn't have
any experience I was I was like you like
I was do I was on my game I was on top
of my stuff in fact a big problem was
that she didn't have an identity outside
of me it was always Jaren and Jane Jaren
and Jane you know years later we had the
conversation and that was a big thing
whatever girls always have excuses but
what I'm getting to I did didn't have
the experience to identify or know like
is she doing this or not but when you do
get in those reps I I mean girls walk in
I just had one walk out a second ago you
pretty much know what's going on in her
head because you've been through so many
you've had so many conversations it's
like anyone who works in sales when you
get in more reps you know at certain
points in the conversation where whether
it's likely to close or not or where you
need to steer the conversation what the
core objections are and you start to put
these things in buckets and you're able
to identify these things and really not
have to think twice about it and then as
you get in more experience you it you uh
you build it into your intuition so then
these things don't even come up so it's
not trying I don't think we're trying to
say that okay your wife is probably out
there banging a bunch of other Chads or
anything but if you don't have the
experience in your pre-marriage past
then how would you really know you
wouldn't even really know what to look
for
so this dude over here dropped the Super
Chat he said you know did he lose his v
card before marriage so
how much experience did you have with
women like were you a virgin or
I mean I I would say for technically
turned for the technical term I would
say yeah I was
yeah okay so so your wife is your one
and only
were you born were you born again is
that why you say technical
um I am born again but not not
necessarily that
um but
um I I've dated before I've uh met my
wife my wife not my first girlfriend
so I mean you've got very very strong
ego Investments I've heard you say that
your uh religious man is fine
um so you've got very strong ego
investments in this working out and
that's fine I hope it does work out I
hope you guys are together forever I
hope you raise uh big and loving family
and you have grandchildren and all that
good stuff but this is where guys go
completely sideways that believe what
you believe is when everything doesn't
work out and if she finds or if she
decides to leave and abandon the
marriage because she thinks that she can
do better and the marriage isn't serving
her this is when a guy's safe world
theory collapses on himself this is when
the guy puts a noose around his neck
this is when he puts a 45 in his mouth
or wants to put a horse tranquilizer
dart in his leg and end things that's
what I'm aiming to stop is to give guys
tools so they understand the reality of
the world I would encourage you to
listen to the rest of the book I know
that you're not going to love it but the
truth of the matter is is you're gonna
get some value out of it if you if you
open your mind to to many of the
concepts that I talk about so here's
what I want to make clear is that and
I've had this thought in conversation
with myself even in my mind if my wife
was there believe me it would I mean it
would be bad for our kids and all that
but it's not like a thing where I'm like
oh no my whole world is going to fall
apart you know I my my investment and um
as Scott asked my investments in Christ
right it's not in my why to the point
where I'm like oh I have she's my
end-all price is my end dollar bill like
and and that that to me that's never
going to leave right so it's not like
I'm gonna like jump off a bridge but
everything you've been talking about
during our conversation has to do with
your ego investments into relationship
and what religion told you relationship
should be you haven't mentioned Christ
once this is the first time you've
mentioned Christ well that's what I'm
talking about that's that's the main
thing that's what when Scott asked
that's yeah that's why I was curious
because in the hierarchy you said man
woman uh like they're man woman children
in the News That's animals but typically
it's God at topic God yeah yeah
I meant like the when it comes to
Leading your family leading your wife
you know you men lead their uh wife and
you know you lead your children together
that's what that's the point I'm making
so definitely Christ is the number one
you know and that that should be um to
me that should be a given you know
and so I'm not worried about if my wife
was to leave I wouldn't be like I
wouldn't like die you know and so for me
it's just like
she's not like my one and only end-all
and be-all as as far as women are yes
she is right I don't care about any
other woman but my wife and that's kind
of where my point is so yeah it's always
it's always guys that that struggle with
the realities of what I talk about that
that go back to where you're going it's
like look if I just subscribe to the
religious narratives if I just lead if I
just do the right thing if I'm a good
father and a good husband I think
everything will work out at the end okay
that's not where I am but what you're
saying is the the statements of facts
the uncomfortable statements the facts
about the relationships that men and
women have on this planet today you
don't like and that's you you're missing
my point even if I didn't like it that's
true it's true regardless but I'm like
you don't like them I mean that's why
you stop listening to the book because
you don't know you don't want to hear it
um I thought probably listen to the book
when you were saying how if you're Alpha
enough basically a woman will basically
allow you to treat her like a prison
mate which I'm
I said that women will break rules for
Alpha men and they'll make rules for
beta men and that's how women operate
today you got into a little bit of
detail there which I'm obviously as a
Christian I'm not going to get into okay
well you don't like the detail that's
fine yeah but but the point is the point
is and I can I can stomach it to go
through it but my my point is and I even
talked with my wife it's just like who
would why would you why would a woman
want you to do that to her you know and
it's just like that's what I'm saying
you're talking about hey no experience
with women dude that's why you don't
understand
because you don't have any experience
with women you've never had a woman have
genuine burning desire for you that will
bend over backwards and do the most
obnoxious things and that's why you're
frustrated with those Notions that they
actually exist probably because
probably because you don't get them in
your own household and you're surprised
to hear them right no I think you're
getting a little bit personal there I
don't think I think that's no but that's
the reality of I don't know
well let me let me say it this way is to
me I see it like I wouldn't want a woman
to want me to do that to her body like
why would you want why why and that I to
me I can't fathom that and the reason
and I'm not saying there are different
people out there no that's my point my
point is the reason why personally for
me I can't fathom that and there are
some different experiences you have
experience with one woman
there's three billion people on the
planet of them are women there's four
billion women you think that all of them
are exactly like your wife and Society
should be exactly like your marriage and
that's not what I'm saying that's why
you're that's why you've got difficulty
with the conversations that I have no I
don't think so this is what I'm saying
carefully what I'm trying I'm listening
to what you're saying but caller as it's
been stated here you're denying
everything
yeah it even for example when you say oh
if my wife left me tomorrow I wouldn't
care I call 100 [ __ ] on that because
I got laid a ton before my first
girlfriend and then who ended up being
my wife I had the experience with women
I thought just like you did like I've
had good relationships bad relationships
I went into my marriage like all right
I'm gonna be the man I'm gonna be her
rock it still failed to really no fault
to my own there were outside influences
and I think you're blind to these things
and it's precisely guys like you that do
have these problems when as Rich says
the safe world theory crumbles because
you've tied up your identity in her so
I'm just saying
what I'm saying though I I hope I I hope
your marriage works out I think I think
the Western world needs more of that
like I'm really pulling for you yeah but
just just be aware that there are
outside influences that you might be
blinded to because you just don't have
the experience that's what I'm trying I
can't tell you
hear me out for a second I can't tell
you how many guys that I've talked to
over the last five or six years that
started where you're at that have booked
me and paid me a lot of money you to
help them figure out how to get back on
their feet and why their wives left them
like I'm not even talking dozens I'm
talking in the hundreds and probably
well over a thousand now so here's the
thing and I know you gotta put that out
there rich but here's the thing
I think you think that I'm this guy
who's just like well I don't know what's
going on and I think that my wife no my
thing is this it's not whatever I had
whether I had experience with my wife or
not is not the point the point is there
that is a different mindset that you
guys are coming from I'm not dragging on
your mindset I'm just saying there are
people out there with different mindset
there are people there are guys out
there that are not going to be like yeah
I'm not going to do that to another
woman's body and there are women out
there that are saying I don't want a guy
doing that to my body you know so that's
what I'm saying there it's not always
about notch count it's not always about
sex it's not always about all those
things are there people out there in
that world that are like that yes it
could it be a high amount yes could it
could we even argue that is the majority
short but majority doesn't even matter
right so what I would tell young man
what I would encourage you to find
different women to spend time with find
different guys spend time with learn
from different older men that are not so
focused on Notch counts that are not so
focused on this kind of culture it's a
culture that I think you have to pull
yourself out of and if you don't pull
yourself out of the post filter yes
you're going to have these issues of
okay so you only have to finish line
here's the problem with that statement
when you say spend time with other women
like we have all spent more time
collectively with way more women than
you see that one wife of 10 years
before that no it's not a brag oh you
I'm taking what you said is go spend
some time with other women I've spent
time with way more women than you dude
so how was that even an argument it's
not you can spend time with 50 000 women
right and they can all be those Trashy
Women you're talking about or you can
spend time with three women and they may
not be the trash
yeah like it sounds black pill dude
no but it sounds black pill like it
sounds like a nihilistic sort of view of
the reality hear me out hear me out bro
hear me out let me finish what I'm
saying now you're interrupting me okay
there's here let me throw this up on the
screen as sort of frame this for you you
know so you understand it I know that
you're not going to like it doesn't
matter to me you are at the point where
we're not going to be friends anyway
um let me see if I can zoom this in a
little bit more
uh come on work with me stream yard
can you guys see that on the screen or
is it too you got there Rich we can see
some which particular box the first
quadrant's just a little cut off on the
left March okay so so there's so there's
four quadrants to the unplugging process
right yeah there's plugged in betas
there's unplugged betas and the
difference between a plugged in beta is
that I mean like I'll just go through
all these bullet points here okay so
plugged in betas are basically the the
bottom 80 of men they're blissfully
ignorant to the way that the world Works
they bend the need of women societal
narratives they put women on a pedestal
they chase women not Excellence they're
mostly nice guys they tell others to
just be themselves try to negotiate
desire use chore play around the house
if you don't know what that is it's if I
do the dishes enough cut the grass
enough then good things will happen you
know in the bedroom they're
insignificant and generally invisible to
most women are physically out of shape
are fragile and allow women sorry and
allow problem women in their lives this
doesn't sound like you you haven't let a
problem woman in your life she's stuck
around when you were sick you're a
personal trainer so I'm assuming you're
not fat you don't look fat in your
picture anyway
um it doesn't sound like
so so there's the plugged in beta the
next level up is the unplug beta and
that's basically the same thing but now
they understand the reality of the world
or they start to understand the rally
often trauma brings them to the point of
unplugging they're they are generally
mad and stay mad when they unplug from
the lies they're very similar to the
plug than beta's mindset now that they
see the truth they wallow in misery they
wallow in misery and they stay at this
point perpetually they very rarely do
the work to level up they stay in a
state of unplug but beta most are
missing uh fastidious Relentless
Pursuits of Excellence uh many are the
smartest person in the room talk about
all that stuff over here our office
talking about early on stereo he's the
smartest person in the room yeah okay
and then and then down over here there's
the plugged in Alpha and you sound like
a combination of a plugged in beta and a
plugged in Alpha right you sound kind of
naturally awful the way that you're
talking about leading the household but
that's that's the best that church is
going to get for you this is the next
level up over here where you're an
unplugged Alpha and the chances of
getting here the way that you're talking
the way that you view these
uncomfortable truths about life is
almost zero and that's probably fine
with you and we're not trying to change
your mind and you're clearly not going
to change our mind about our experiences
and the realities of the world I mean
this is why we're at where you know
where we're at we're far more
influential like I could go down the
list well you kind of broke it down for
me and I think like what you said like
the smartest person in the room I think
we were in Stereo before we got into the
conversation and mom was saying and I
was like where do you get that from but
I think that's what it is it's like this
unplugged beta mindset just to use your
lingo I don't believe in necessarily but
it's like oh women are this women are
that my thing is it's the culture if
you're in this box yes this is all true
if you're living in that box and what
I'm saying is get out of that box that's
what I would tell young men like yeah so
what you're telling guys is to plug back
into the lies and everything will be
fine Blissful ignorance is the way it
goes
that's the whole culture right there
even that uh the beta the plug beta
that's the culture of itself right get
out of that culture too I to me it's
just a culture that you're living in I
think Scott was talking about it with
knowledge counts and all this stuff like
whoa what's your announcement I knew
that was going to come up oh it's not
coming like I don't even let's say I had
a big knock she almost had a small nice
account it doesn't even matter I don't
even want to say any of all that
craziness for me yeah I know you make
that face small because that's the
culture you guys are in and that's what
I'm trying to say there are young men
yeah when you have more experience you
have more insights so when you have
things that you've done and you've lived
in the life and you've experienced the
world you haven't experienced the people
that haven't done those things don't
have there's there's obviously
importance when it comes to that for
example your statement like all these
easy Trashy Women or I don't remember
exactly what the context and the way
they're easy I don't know but they're
definitely trashy yeah but I I hear this
a lot you married a woman that's not a
virgin
yeah
okay so was she trashy
what the thing is that in her past she
has a pass right and she wouldn't she
wouldn't say that that's the person she
wants to be with be in her past
because that makes a difference like for
you guys or whatever because I know you
guys think this is going to be like kind
of Andrew Tate thing whatever like two
guys right so I know oh well that's not
a lot that's not a lot so it doesn't
matter so for me that's why I want to
bring that stuff up because I'm the
perfect example she's the perfect
example right for example that's the
perfect example of a perfect woman
because when you when you got married
she was not Chase she was not a virgin
okay that's fine as long as you guys I'm
not saying you guys should see her that
way but here's a question for you
because you're you're saying Nosh cat
doesn't matter so you married your wife
at two guys that's actually not too bad
um but if she had 200 guys it still
wouldn't matter because you're saying
doesn't matter to me it wouldn't matter
Superior girl you marry a girl with a
200 body count yeah if she if she had
200 or two
if that was my wife okay the wife that
I'm married to right now if it was the
same person I would wouldn't matter it
wouldn't matter to me was two or two
hundred it's my point is what I'm saying
yeah
you didn't even get to my red flag
chapter dude because when you're talking
about Trashy Women you're talking about
staying away from trash a woman and a
woman that's got a notch count of 200 is
trash she's a very bad choice for
marriage
would you buy a car with 200 000 miles
on it and paper price for it like it's a
new car yeah yeah like brand new I want
to explain this because I don't drive
but I want to explain this because I
think this is very important right
it's not about
what her past was like or my password or
anyone's past was like Yeah women are
concerned with a man's future men need
to be concerned with a woman's past I
got you you completely overlooking a
woman that's been with 200 guys tells me
that you're plugged into society's
comforting lies you can be as religious
as you want you can go to church every
day of the weeks three times a day that
is not going to serve you over a
long-term basis as a guy if you believe
that that's fine I hope it works out for
you but it probably won't out of balance
of probabilities I think you're missing
the point there rich I think you're
missing the point at all dude you're the
one that's missing the point because
you're calling women that are uh like
are promiscuous trash but then you'd say
well I would completely Overlook a woman
as wife material if she'd been with two
inner guys right she just got right with
God or something like that right at the
moment she is not a promiscuous woman
then yes right but if she's still
promiscuous then she's trash if she's
still promiscuous then it's trashed if
she stops being promiscuous then she's
holding on the track
the best indicator behavior is past
Behavior yeah it doesn't work that way
Matt it really doesn't work that way you
know dude and the reason I took issue go
ahead go ahead Jordan sorry the reason I
take issue because I hear a lot of guys
especially my personal life guys on my
channel like oh well yeah you had
another girl come in she must be trash
like no most of the girls I date they're
actually really cute they're shy they're
feminine they're insecure but it's
because I've developed myself to a point
where women want a guy like me so I hear
that a lot it's I'm not saying that you
are but I hear that a lot for more like
black belt type guys like oh well she
put out the first night she must be
trash I'm like I'm like the second third
guy she's ever had like right let's that
doesn't make me trashy okay so let's do
this so we're just going to agree to
disagree I got the chat getting
frustrated and wanted me to cut you from
the show so we can move on to something
else I appreciate you expressing your
views and your uh issues with a concept
that I've talked about you really
haven't presented anything that's a
better solution in my eyes I don't think
the other the chat or anybody else I
probably would dude you've been on the
past hour yeah but I've been cut off a
couple of times especially when I'm
getting to the point no no dude you got
to the point every single time you were
talking when you're talking about a
point so I'm letting you go thanks for
hopping on brother I wish you the best
that would just keep going I would just
keep going on so
that's that's just a pla that's just an
example of a plugged in beta you know
that's all that is right I mean you know
like I hope his ego Investments with his
marriage and his life and everything
work out but at the end of the day
no hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out